hello wordsmiths the word we're
featuring in this video is invalid
that's right it's not true or rather
that's what it means
incorrect false not accepted
it's an adjective
it comes from Latin where the prefix in
means not and the word valirus means
strong
so it literally means not strong or weak
a weak argument a weak law someone's
argument might be invalid because it was
based on faulty evidence
when you look at invalid can you
recognize any other English words
anything with in or vowel in it
take 10 seconds of this music break to
come up with some possibilities
here we go
[Music]
validate right to prove that something's
right or true I validate your parking I
validate your feelings
get you with the big validation stamp
um value meaning something that has
Worth right strength in worth and
inability which is when you cannot do
something there's ability right when it
can do a thing and in ability which is
its opposite
let's spend some time talking about that
in prefix honestly because it can get
confusing
there are two different prefixes in
English both coming from Latin that are
spelled and pronounced the same way both
in i n that have different meanings
in or sometimes IM I am means not
exactly like the native English un like
unlikable unlovely
think invalid impolite infrequent
right not correct not polite not
frequent and then there's in in that
means inside
this also sometimes appears as e n n
like Insight looking inward or insert
which is to put something into something
else or with en you can have it as
enlist or enrich but today in this video
we're talking about the in that means an
the in that means not will return to
this topic for sure in other videos now
let's use invalid in a sentence I can't
log in it says my password is invalid
makes you Furious when something's
invalid it doesn't work it isn't correct
when it's valid it's proper and
appropriate but when it's invalid it
won't be accepted it's no good you know
it is good though
you
you're good I believe in you and the
vocabulary Journey that we're on
together
you can learn anything
David out